so let's say I
am studying architecture at University
and I'm thinking you know I I want to
actually be an architect I don't want to
be one of those you know architect
dropouts that start a YouTube channel
for now I want to study architecture I
want to build my professional reputation
I want to network with the right people
maybe I'm active on LinkedIn maybe I'm
going to these conferences and just
trying to build up a decent body of work
but I'm also thinking in the back of my
mind you know I can see myself based on
the sort of person I am you know back
when I was in school I was selling candy
bars whatever um I'm thinking maybe I
want to start my own firm one day and
preferably sooner rather than later once
I've got a bit of experience under my
belt and hm maybe this personal brand
stuff could be interesting in that
position let's say someone is a
professional in a traditional career and
they like the idea of a personal brand
firstly what's what's the benefit of
them trying to build a personal brand
within a professional industry and then
how would they go about it well I mean
obviously it will give you options
further down the line that's you know
that's a big you know
a big benefit for sure um in terms of
going ahead and actually starting it and
doing it I would be in this day and age
I'd be really really upfront with my
boss and I'd say hey I'm thinking of
starting a YouTube channel where uh I'm
going to show people how to draw or how
to use CAD or how to make 3D models or
whatever it is that people do in
architecture you know offices My Father
Was An Architect so I've kind of grown
up around that a little bit um and uh I
just thought before I start doing it I'm
not going to mention my company that I'm
working for or anything like that your
opinions are my own and all that sort of
stuff but would you have a problem with
it or not because you're better off
being upfront with that and getting the
green light from your boss than you
would do putting an entire year into it
the boss is not liking it and then
getting into trouble that wouldn't be a
good situation to be in at all but it
would certainly give you opportunities
further down the line it creates options
which is never a bad thing at all you
know but Ally honestly you know we're
sitting here talking about this
if you'd have told me you know 17 18
years ago when I opened the doors to my
first
business that I would be writing a
bestselling book on building a personal
brand business that I would be making
money to speak in front of complete
strangers on stages around the world um
and have you know tens of thousands of
people tuning into my show every week
like I would not have seen this coming
at all this has not been planned or at
least initially it wasn't right I'd like
to think that I've been a little bit
more strategic in the last seven or
eight years but at least at first like I
didn't even realize I had a personal
brand until I got my first book deal and
then I realized it was one one
particular conversation that I had with
the Publishers uh who said my first book
was called virtual freedom and they said
that they liked the concept of the book
and the proposal for the book because it
felt like it was the Outsourcing life
section of the 4-Hour Work Week that
never got printed kind of thing was like
the next step kind of thing um and
that's great and that's going to put you
on another pedestal Chris and I was like
well okay that's great and everything
but I'm not really I don't really I just
want to help people like I'm not I'm not
writing this book to go on to you know
to move up a pedestal or two like this
is just what I've gone through in the
last four five six years I burned out in
20 2009 and then had to come back from
that and part of that process was hiring
a whole bunch of people to replace
myself some virtual some not but then
you know I started blogging and
podcasting and all that sort of stuff in
2010 about vas and virtual teams and all
of a sudden BOS I'm getting a publishing
deal because I'm the VA
guy right so okay great I've always
wanted to become a public a published
author that's a goal that you know let's
take that off uh you know the the the
list and we'll move on from that but
then what happened was after the book
came came out people started to say to
me how did you do that how did you get
the book deal and I started reverse
engineering it back and I said I got the
book deal because I was publishing
content three times a week on my blog
and I was podcasting every week and you
know I was doing YouTube videos every
now and then I was on Twitter you know
back when you know Twitter was like
really cool when it first started right
and all this sort of stuff and reverse
engineer back you realize actually I'm
building that personal brand up over a
period of time and it just ended up
culminating with a book deal so then
that's where upo was born that was where
if I can do it for nothing there's no
reason why I can't help other people do
it as well and that that was where youo
was born is there is is there a way to
build a personal brand without I guess
quote creating content or is that really
the main lever I mean I think there
probably is uh I I don't think you need
to you know one of the one of the
easiest ways for us to spread our
message our opinions our
ideas and our thoughts today is doing
exactly what we're doing right now it's
getting in front of other PE other
people's audiences right um you know
your people will tune in and I'm a
little Marite right I people either like
me or they don't like me there's not a
lot of messy Middle with me and I'm
actually fine with that as well I think
pretty much every content creator should
be like that you know you either love it
or hate it like my might have it they've
got it down right in terms of marketing
like they lean into that love it or hate
it thing so well and it works
brilliantly and I think the same could
be said for personal Brands as well but
this was not something that I really
thought was going to happen but now I've
just rolled into it and I think that the
majority of people who jump on board
with the idea of building a personal
brand um and they understand the power
of it and there is a certain amount of
responsibility involved as well
obviously as you get more and more known
and respected uh your opinions and what
you say online really matter
particularly but no I I don't think you
need to create content yourself but I
think in today's world you definitely
need to
be you need to be in front of other
people hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye-bye